what is going on everybody and welcome
to part
five of the generative python
transformers videos
in this video uh we are going to be
hopefully building the
trainer and actually training this model
now we are training this model on
nowhere near enough data at the moment
we only have
76 000 basically uh samples
uh which is just just not enough we
should have
millions hundreds of millions
or billions um so yeah this is just not
enough but
um i am curious just to see like could
we get anywhere with this little amount
of data
but also to be clear i will after this
video once we see that everything
is working and training i am not going
to be using this data set moving forward
i do have 100 gigs
of python data i i'm going to build the
file
this exact same way um so yeah so just
keep that in mind
keep that in mind um but but for now
we're going to work on this small one
just to see if it works
we are also going to train gpt2 from
scratch
the other option is to fine-tune it so
the p
in gpt is pre-trained the idea here
being that you know openai
can train the gpt-2 model on their like
whatever it is
is it like 10 000 gp gpus
they have some absurd number of gpus it
might even be a hundred thousand all i
know in my head is it's absurd
and uh at least uh behind me i do have a
pretty absurd machine not going to lie
um not quite 10 000 gpus but it's got
four of the a 180 gig
gpus in it so we will be able to do
quite a bit of training on there but it
certainly doesn't compare to 10 000
i'm guessing they're v100s anyway
um so we're going to train this one from
scratch only because i
i've played with gpt2 um just like the
pre-trained models
and they're not like it's not i mean
it's impressive
for like natural language processing it
really is very impressive
um but it doesn't scream to me that oh
you're gonna have to use this whereas
like probably the gpt3 model
there are so many parameters in that
model that i
think to train it locally even on
something
crazy like that is just not even
remotely possible
so i think that's the difference uh
we'll find out and
i totally plan in this series to include
using a pre-trained model and then
fine-tuning it to
python code just my suspicion is there's
so many little differences between
regular spoken language and python code
that if we could train it from scratch
we might as well
so that's what i'm going to do so feel
free to share your opinion below
um but we'll see if it works and then
like i said i will definitely use a much
larger the full-size data set uh moving
forward
so um to train i'm going to just
continue
referencing all the things i showed you
in the previous video
uh so the first order of business uh
i think what i'm going to do we'll copy
tokenizer
i'm going to make it a new file i'm
going to call it uh
train dot pi that's fine
um i was tempted to get rid
of like this essentially uh but i think
i'll leave i mean might as well just be
all one file for now
i don't really think there's a problem
with that so i'm gonna leave that
so we have our uh tokenizer the
tokenizer itself is already the gpt2
tokenizer
so we're kind of we're all set there
essentially
all we have to add is
the we have to kind of like define our
model
we have to define our data set
and then with hugging face you need to
define your like data collater i might
be mispronouncing
that but anyway it's a thing that like
batches your data set
for the model to train on so uh
those are like the things that the big
things that are at least off the top of
my head that we need to do
so let us go ahead and do that now i've
already
lost the uh yes there we are
this so um so yeah so we will
uh like essentially pick up where are we
in this tutorial basically here the
config
now we are going to use a different
config we're using the gpt2 config
so that is let's see if i can find this
where is the g there we go okay so we'll
go ahead and
set once we have our tokenizer done i
think that's the next thing that we'll
do
uh we'll just kind of follow that
tutorial so config
and in our case we've already actually
imported it this gpt2 config
so gpt2 config and a lot of the settings
are
uh let's see what they did what were the
settings that they did in their config
vocab size so um i want to say the so
for the
burt model uh it does have a different
vocab size we're going to
actually we're just going to define our
own um
and we're just going to use all the
defaults we could
i don't know if we can get away if we
can change this
because right now our maximum context
anyway like we could try to change the
context
we could also change layers i think i'm
just going to leave everything alone the
only thing we're going to define here
is um
the uh we've got the vocab size
and then the so let's just start
so we'll say vocab size
will be equal to tokenizer dot
focab size and again we're doing this
because we're training it from scratch
we have our own unique tokenizer and all
that
you could just use the pre-trained
gpt-2 with the gpt2 pre-trained
tokenizer
and you can get that from hugging face
it's actually really simple to
use their pre-trained models like if you
saw the chatbot video
we used uh dilo gpt which um
i if you saw that you saw it's so easy
so so i i i'm excited for that reason i
will test
the pre-trained but for now we're going
to do our own so we're going to set our
vocab size
and then we also want to notify it of
the bos
token and the eos token so beginning of
sentence end of sentence
and that is tokenizer i think it's just
dot bos token
it's id and then this one
equals tokenizer dot
eos token underscore
id so that is the config
for our model now
uh once we have that we can define our
actual model
and that is model equals uh
this gpt to lm link which stands for
language model
head model and then um
now we're ready to actually do the data
set thing so um
that was kind of my only sore spot with
hugging face going through these
tutorials
uh the original tutorial
like builds their own data set here um
which i i presume would still work this
this version locks you into torch utils
data set but if you're using like
tensorflow
i'm assuming you could use tensorflow's
data set stuff so if you knew
either one of those really well i mean
maybe you could continue using that
uh then here in the updated notebook
they use where are you
this uh from transformers import line by
line data set the problem with this
is it loads everything at once into
memory
which wouldn't be a problem if you have
a ton of memory
but it not only does it load everything
into memory it like multiplies
by like 20.
it's an absurd multiple so the uh or
maybe even
let's see i would say it multiplies it
by like 40.
so on this machine here i have
uh 512 gigabytes of
memory and the 75 gig data set does not
fit
though the one that i tested was like
eight gigs eight gigs does fit and it
uses something like 350 gigs
of um of memory
so that is absurd
so it's not efficient it's not very good
now there is
a better method and the new kind of
standard method
is to use the this like data sets
library
and so that is what we're going to use
but even that is not very well
documented at least in my opinion
i did have to enlist the help of daniel
to help me figure out how the heck do i
make this work
so to do that it'll be we'll do from
data sets
we are going to import uh load
underscore
data set and again uh to get this it you
know pip 3 install
install data sets like that
um so we'll come down here and now we'll
specify our data set then we specify the
collater
uh the trainer and then we train so
let's do that
so uh we've got our model oh we need to
instantiate that model hello there we go
so we have our model uh now for this
um we'll just start we'll say data
equals
load data set and then here uh
this takes basically what kind of data
is it it's a text data set
and then the data files equals paths
and that paths was defined up here in a
previous
i think we did it in the tokenizer
so this i believe is kind of our like
generator
um so this will load our data set in
like a lazy loading type fashion
but then we still have to tokenize it to
be fed into our model
we have to define how will we tokenize
that and and the way that you
apply your tokenizer is like with this
dot
set as i understand it set transform
i've pro i think i've said it already in
this series but again i
am not an expert on any of this like i
just i'm this is me tinkering um this is
my understanding of how it's done
so yeah okay so uh to
to do that uh basically you're gonna say
data
we'll see data let's say uh data
just so it's the same as in my notes i
said data set equals that and then data
set
essentially what you want to do is do
set underscore
transform
and we well in this case we'd like to
encode
that with our tokenizer now to do that
we need to
define an encode and encode
is going to take in lines of information
and it needs to tokenize those lines
now this part was the hard part i could
not figure out like okay
well what is what is these like lines
objects like what are lines coming from
load data set and then
i don't think it was documented very
well anywhere i wish it was better
documented so
anyway this is from the help of daniel
essentially what we're going to do is
return and then we use our tokenizer
and we use that on lines and then it's
lines
text and i like i said i think i guess
this produces via generator as sort of
dictionary type object guessing just
guessing
add i'm just going to copy this actually
and then i want to make a fix so paste
so
add special tokens yes uh truncation
we would like to truncate it but the max
length not 128 we'll make it 512.
and then probably later we'll change
this to be 1024 because gpg2's default
context length is 1024. we're gonna use
512 for now
so i'm just again i'm just trying to see
if this works
so uh set transform and code
okay so that's done and then finally
after that
we say the data set equals data set
train
so okay so now that we've got that uh
we're ready to do the data collater and
we don't have that yet so let's go ahead
and
import that that's from uh actually
we'll just do it right here
uh data collater
uh you run over my face
uh i think i'll just put it uh
well we can do a do this yeah
um data
data collater
what is it data collater for language
modeling okay good enough
um i kind of want to put it over here
there we go
uh so now that we have that
uh we will copy that we're gonna come
down here
and we're gonna say data underscore
collater
equals that very very long name
like why do they say foreign language
like everywhere else they use lm
uh this should just be like dc4lm
or uh data call
yeah anyway you can make that names
order anyway
um so data collater and then here
we specify our tokenizer equals
our tokenizer um mlm
this stands for a masked language model
and in this case it is and then here mlm
probability probability this is actually
the default
uh this is just what's the probability
of assigning a masked
a mask token so with the burp model
the mask you know can be just kind of
anywhere randomly and then the model is
trained to like fill in the mask
and then it uses tokens before and after
that mask to fill it in whereas a gpt
model will only use tokens that precede
um the mask so with that in mind
i don't really know how mlm probability
is applied
so does that mean at each token along a
sequence it has a 15
chance of being masked
if so then it will only fill it
using the previous um you know tokens
and that might be very very very few
tokens
so i don't really know um if someone
knows
uh let me know because maybe for a gpt-2
model
you might want something more like that
because in theory we're going to have
like 500 tokens
not like that i'm sorry um give it more
like a one percent chance or something
like that
anyway um i'm going to keep it at the
default
again just trying to see if it works but
yeah something to think about
uh so data collateral so we'll yeah
we'll just keep all the defaults
on that uh and then
do i think we are ready let's import our
final two imports so we're gonna say uh
from transformers
we are going to import trainer and
training
ergo mens we'll come down here
and um i think we're using mostly the
same ones
as the uh tutorial used
let's find those yeah
essentially this um i'll copy and paste
these
and then i'll we'll make some changes
and then before i forget i'm just gonna
say it is trainer.train
so we'll just train the model and
do they save it i can't remember if they
show how to say i think it's like
trainer.save or something
yeah so we'll do this before we forget
that
too cool okay
so we'll make some changes now um
so first of all our output directory
will be gpit
true per gpu this actually has changed
it is this per gpu train batch size
becomes per
device train batch size if you run it
the other one will work it'll just tell
you that it's been updated so it's this
now
i'm going to set this to 10 just so we
test it locally to see if it works
uh the gpt-2 model is is quite a large
model so
if it doesn't work on your machine
you'll want to probably
edit the config
and set set way less layers
a different size and so on so if you
have a small
baby gpu keep that in mind
it might be tough um
and then while we're thinking about it
when we save the model let's save it to
chi
pi bro
gpi t and then before i forget let's go
ahead and just make that directory i
can't remember if it'll make it for us
g pi t so boop
cool um
save steps we're going to save every 100
this will essentially just save like a
checkpoint file for us
so 100 again this is a very large model
the model that they use
in their uh tutorial is like a much
smaller
model i think that's why they're
allowing 10 000 steps
um prediction loss
and then i'm not really sure
remove unused i have this in my notes
and i'm not sure why
i'm going to keep it in there so i just
added that one
uh number of training epoxy at one save
total limit two this is how many
uh checkpoints to save at a time that
way just each checkpoint is gonna be
like 500 megabytes
so you wouldn't want to save a ton of
them
um
maybe we're ready i'm sure i'm
forgetting something we'll just save it
and
we'll find out what we're forgetting
um once we see this works i'm going to
move things over to the
dgx station and see how long
will it actually take but before then i
just want to eradicate
your errors
do we pass i guess we have to pass the
config in there
did i really forget that yeah okay okay
yeah click to find config and never used
it
that's okay a fancier editor would have
told us
um okay i don't recognize this one at
all data files
uh let's see
data files where is
it's just data underscore files
yeah so um
this needs a data underscore files and
then it's equal to paths so
data underscore files i've lost my
there it is
take 97.
maybe oh we are stepping
uh i think i'm gonna break that 46
minutes
and
watch uh nvidia smi
what are we doing 12 gigs okay
that was really laggy hopefully that
didn't murder the recording but anyway
okay so that did train
it was 12 gigs for
um a batch size of 10.
so uh what would that be
12 we could probably times
five so maybe we'll say a batch size of
50 or 60
for the dgx station we'll find out
so this file is ready so actually what
i'm going to do is i'm going to move the
files
to there and then we'll shell in and
then we'll we'll go from there
okay i think i've moved everything over
there so ssh
uh dgx a100 oh my god
um
nobody look at my password please thank
you uh alrighty
uh let's go cd uh
raid and then what was the directory g
pi t
video cool uh
all right so now python3 train dot pi
oh i didn't change the batch size
hold up wait
uh nanotrain dot pi can we just
oh we gotta make a couple of changes
here actually
dang it okay i made a couple of quick
edits there
uh the one thing one change that i made
is import os
and then here we're just setting the uh
available
cuda devices uh the reason for that i
will show in a moment and then the only
other thing i did was set the batch size
uh to 60. for now
we'll see if that works that might
actually blow memory we'll find out
so that's 60 per gpu so we will exit
so effectively what 60 times 4 240 um
the batch size will be 240. if we pop
into
in fact i think uh i think i'll just
open another terminal
uh ssh dgx a100 oh my gosh
and if i go watch nvidia
smi uh what we'll see here
is why i set the gpus the way i did so
not all gpus are created equal this gpu
is just the display gpu so
the a100s we don't connect any monitors
or anything to them
uh but the what we if to display the you
know a monitor
it has this little display card and it
only it only has two gigs
of memory whereas the the a100s have
81 gigs of memory so
that is why we're here so this is gpu012
we want to ignore gpu 3 because if we
try to stick a batch size of 60
on gpu 3 it will not end well
so we want to use 0 1 2 and 4
for our gpus so let me set this over
here for now
and let's go ahead and run train dot pi
hopefully we didn't kill anything by
breaking it like we did
why can't i get this to there we go i
just wanted to show that while we uh
start stepping i kind of want to show
both somehow there we go
and we're off and we're only we're
maxing so the main gpu this is kind of
like your
uh it's serving everything so uh oh
it might actually run out of memory
oh we're hitting 78. uh-oh
man there's some serious fluctuations in
um in memory here
usually the main gpu has more memory
usage
what i'm sorry what was it locally
i can't remember what my local time was
i'm sorry that's so that's so insane
this is gonna take three minutes i think
oh man
i think locally it was gonna take like
two hours
[Laughter]
oh god okay yeah
that's insane um
okay i guess we'll we'll come back and
in a couple minutes i don't
so i think you normally get um
like metrics after every 500 steps or
something like that
so i don't even think we'll have got
like we're just not going to get any
metrics
that whole thing trained in four minutes
that's just absurd oh man
um okay so now what i think i'm going to
do is i'm going to actually move the
model
how do i want to do this i think i'm
going to move the model back locally i
mean i don't need
mostly you just want the dgx station for
training so
so i'm going to actually copy the model
back over so the model just for the
record
if we cd to g pi t
uh we'll actually see multiple things
here we'll see the
so here um
let's see config.json let me let's see
the end of this checkpoint i forget
which
oops uh checkpoint let's say 200. uh if
it's all three
yeah it's all three of those things it
looks like so excuse me back
so really these three files define the
model um
so this was this was the model at the
end of training so we'll
we'll just copy the whole thing over but
um you could either
load in the you could load in via
checkpoint by like when we go to load
the model you'll see it in a second but
we could say checkpoint 200 checkpoint
300 or we could load in and say hey the
model is located at this gpt directory
and any of those would work just for the
record okay so i've got the things
copied over we check the gpt directory
again
we'll probably use this one since this
will be like the latest and greatest
again i don't um we'll probably see a
bunch of gobbly goop here
and we'll probably need to train for
multiple epochs um but
we'll go ahead and code it and then i'll
train it for multiple epochs probably
and then come back and show you the
results
um so uh trained.pine
let's say uh use model i guess we'll
call this
use model dot pi
and we'll leave everything here as
really no problem i don't think
leaving all this uh the thing that will
change is
um let's see gpt2
head model um lm
yeah basically this
[Music]
delete all this and rather than
the config stuff we're going to say it's
actually a gpt2
lm head model um dot from
underscore pre-trained how did it know
did we already do we do that for oh okay
so it's the same kind of call from the
uh tokenizer
so how did you know to autocomplete that
um and then
we'll specify where is that so it's g pi
t uh and then um because
we are using torch we need to
2.2 cuda so we get nice fast results
and now we have our model now to use the
model uh we essentially
are going to have input um
how do we want to how do i how do i want
to do this um
yeah so we will do while true
uh we'll just say input can't do that
imp equals uh input
uh that
and then we will uh go ahead and
uh tokenize the input so we'll just say
input underscore ids equals and this
will be
tokenizer dot uh n code
and we are going to encode whatever we
did
imp on and then return underscore
tensors
will be pt for pi torch and then again
we want this to go
to our cuda device which i don't really
actually think
i'm not sure it would actually matter
but i think we want to lower case this
um token text
let's see this goes in um
[Music]
uh for now we'll i'll add this but
i don't think we're going to test
anything it won't come to this i don't
think in this video but
uh input equals imp dot replace
and we will replace shoot how do i wanna
um no i'm gonna leave this alone for now
we're not gonna mess with that
um i was gonna handle for the new line
character stuff but i think we'll leave
it
um input id to cuda what else do we need
so now we're gonna specify the
uh beam output from this model beam
output and that will be equal to a model
dot
generate and here we are going to
generate from
the input ids we are going to say the
max and in fact let's
put this down here too max length
um length we'll set that to 512.
we'll say the num beams is
10 the temperature we will set
to um i think the default 0.7
so number of beams is like basically
it's going to
reach attack it's going to reach a token
a mask token
and what we're going to what model
generates going to do is it's going to
generate a string of text until it
reaches an
end of sentence token essentially or
hits the max length
but each token along the way has
um uh let's say a score or something of
of
you know which one do we choose but
there there might be an array of
possible tokens and then each token that
you pick
that changes the next tokens
possibilities so
beams and temperature can be used to
give you a variety of outputs to
possibly choose from at the very end
at least from what i've seen it doesn't
seem to be making any difference for me
here
this is something i plan to play with
maybe from a pre-trained model
uh to see if if that makes a huge impact
but so far i haven't noticed that it it
does and again if i'm saying something
stupid
feel free to correct me uh no repeat
engram size uh i think this is
literally the repetition of um
outputs so it's and i think i think
um and it doesn't seem to include
special tokens again i
this i'm knowing less and less as we go
through uh these parameters
but in this case i'm gonna set it to
five and again all this is gonna do is
it's gonna stop
like the same exact uh token from being
outputted
i think five times but again i could be
totally wrong there
um that one we can tinker with that and
i'll show you how the output differs
because
that one does seem to make a difference
and then here num
return sequences uh i'm gonna set this
to one because again
i have not noticed that num beams in
temperature so temperature is like a
degree of
uh like uniqueness or randomness
um and again modifying this it's a you
know from zero to one
modifying this i have not noticed from
the uh
trend from scratch models that i've
played with i haven't noticed that it
makes any difference
so then finally um
right now we just have the one sequence
so there's really no big deal but
four beam in beam output
uh four beam in beam output uh we are
going to say
out equals tokenizer dot decode
that beam out and then f out will be
equal to
out dot and in this case we are going to
go ahead and replace
any new line with
not that uh an actual new line character
so we when we display it on the screen
uh
let's see do we have we did bring that
in so we'll go ahead and
print green string
i think that's going to be a string but
we'll just make sure uh
and cool okay
let's see if that works uh we are no
longer training test test sss
uh loading the model cool cool i think
we're good let's go ahead
again this is probably going to be
disgusting i don't think it's going to
work we're going to have to make
many more uh epochs on that tiny data
set if it will ever work
but let's just see
probably should just have defined some
sort of input but
whatever print
hello
dude you're really slow
um okay so
um that i'm that's actually better than
what i was expecting in all honesty
because this is such a young model
[Applause]
uh i'm kind of surprised that it looks
this good
[Laughter]
um wow i kind of want to like
train for 10 more epochs or something
and then come back and show you guys
uh i really didn't expect it to look
like this and even at all
um so obviously this is unacceptable
python code but it was
again an unacceptable size of data and
and
even then it was unacceptable training
time of like
four minutes um yes it was on the
behemoth machine but uh still not enough
uh okay um yeah i guess i'll do you guys
a solid i will train
maybe for 10 epochs i don't know if i
want to wait 40 minutes on a model that
i know is not going to be very good
maybe i'll do like five epochs or
something i don't know anyway i'll make
it i'll come back
and i'll show you what we get with a
slightly better model than this
all right and we're back so uh the i did
seven epochs that took 26 minutes and 44
seconds on our very very pathetically
small data set
but i just wanted to do it because i was
pretty impressed with these results
on one ebox i just wanted to see it real
quick this is the tensorboard
not really too much to write home about
the epochs of course went up learning
weight rate does decay
automatically with these models uh and
we can see that
uh loss let's uh set this down
lost and indeed uh decline so
um okay
let's check the results now so i have
actually already moved
over um the files and if i recall right
uh we don't actually need to change
anything because we load
the gpit model from pre-trained i've
copied that model over
so i actually think uh i think we could
just
uh well break out of this uh see control
c to break i didn't
realize that was still running run that
again hopefully we'll load the
new model
and uh let's go ahead and print
again hello i don't know we'll just do
that let's see what happens
i just want to see it
show let's go up to the top here
print hello uh so at least you can see
we did not close off our quotes or the
parentheses
it went ahead and did that for us it
also went ahead
and started populating with some code
my guess is our data set is so small
that this is probably
identical to something in our data set
at least to some extent so that's
interesting
let's check a couple of autocompletes so
what if we say
well first let's see what happens when
we just import i'm just curious like
what do we
grab when we import uh and then also
maybe like import numpy and then see
does it suggest initially as np
so import it does cis it does the system
check and this is actually
um isn't that pretty identical to what
we had up here
mirror oh not no wow it is a little
different
interesting uh let's go ahead and import
numpy let's just see if it
finishes as np let's say
and the other thing to note is it is
indeed doing like new lines
and white space to some extent uh
correctly
so like if colon and it does the white
space
it did the new line i am we're we are uh
replacing out the new line but anyway
let's see if it did np it did
oh i can't this is such a
baby model on the dumbest data set
uh and that actually works
dang i mean this is kind of silly
uh like passing self to a regular
function like it's not the greatest but
as far as
a line complete on a typical import
not bad uh import torch
let's see what happens um i
am i'm really surprised i really am uh
we
this is like nothing
import torch sis i'm if my pie check
weren't
right i don't know what the heck all
this is but else define
itself i mean it knows uh some stuff i
mean it's pretty cute not gonna lie
um wow
i'm impressed um wow it's gonna be hard
to top that but okay
uh what we're gonna do or what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna train the much
larger data set now um
[Music]
see what results from that uh and then
possibly after that
increase the length the context length
so like right now
the default is 1024 but we're the bit
the longest sequence we're passing could
possibly be 512.
so uh i think i'll maybe make a new
make a proper data set of that length um
and then maybe train that one too i
don't know
anyway uh yeah wow those are really
impressive results
uh i'm i'm shocked i really am
quite surprised i cannot believe that uh
with a mere 70 000 samples in like 20
minutes
or 26 minutes of training on the it is
on the a100s
uh that would take considerably longer
on a regular machine like even on these
rtx titans that would take a very long
time
many hours
man i cannot believe that it did that
um okay yeah i'm gonna train a bigger
model and we'll come back if you guys
have questions comments suggestions
whatever feel free to leave those below
otherwise i'll see you guys in another
video
you